[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES SMITH: Welcome to this
talk about Google Play App
Signing.
This is a really
exciting moment for us.
We've been working on this
product for nearly a year,
so it's great to be able
to talk to you about it.
I'm James, I'm the product
manager for App Signing,
and this is--
ANTHONY MORRIS: Hi, I'm Anthony.
I'm the engineering lead
for Google Play App Signing.
JAMES SMITH: So let's start
by outlining the problem
that we're trying to solve.
Android requires that all
APKs be digitally signed
with an app signing
key and a certificate
before they can be installed.
When you sign an
APK, the signing tool
attaches a certificate
to the APK.
The certificate serves
as a fingerprint,
which uniquely associates
your APK with you
and your corresponding
private app signing key.
This helps Android ensure that
any future updates to your APK
are authentic and come
from the original author.
You must use the same app
signing key and certificate
throughout the lifetime of
your app in order for users
to be able to install
new versions of your app.
Maintaining the
security of your key
is therefore of
critical importance,
both to you and your users.
If a third party
should be able to take
your key without your
knowledge or permission,
that person could sign and
distribute apps maliciously
that replace your authentic
apps or corrupt them.
Such a person could also
sign and distribute apps
under your identity.
Your private key is required
for signing all future versions
of your app.
If you lose or
misplace your key,
you will not be able to publish
updates to an existing app.
You cannot generate a
previously generated key.
Your only options,
then, would be
to publish a new app
under a new package name
and ask all of your
users to move across.
This would obviously be
a terrible experience.
Developers who take such
care in grafting great apps
and wonderful
experiences for users
shouldn't need to be
experts in security.
You shouldn't ever
be in the situation
that the president
of RV AppStudios
had to face when they
were getting started.
So that's why we've been
working on a solution,
and you may have heard that
we launched this product.
App Signing is an
optional program
for developers that provides
a secure means of handling
your APK signing key.
Previously, the burden for
signing and protecting keys
was entirely on each
individual app developer,
and we've seen instances of
keys being lost or compromised.
And in those situations,
there was nothing
that we could do to help.
With Google Play App
Signing, developers' keys
are stored on infrastructure,
Google's infrastructure,
and developers benefit from
Google's ongoing investment
in technical security.
So let me run through
how this works.
Today, a developer signs their
APK with an app signing key.
The signature gets
attached to the APK,
and the app is uploaded
to Google Play.
Play sends an exact copy of
the APK, signature and all,
to the user, and the
user gets the app
signed by the original key.
All subsequent updates
follow the same path.
With Google Play App Signing,
things look a little different.
Now, the developer signs
their APK with an upload key.
The upload key signature
is attached to the APK,
and the developer
uploads that APK to Play.
The upload key is used by Google
to authenticate the developer,
and that's its only purpose.
The upload key can
therefore be reset.
Play re-signs the APK with
the original app signing key,
and the user gets an APK
signed with the original key,
just like in the
scenario that is today.
So how does this
solve your problem?
Well, we've had several
partners using Google Play App
Signing for a while
now, and the feedback
has been really positive.
Here, Robinhood speaks
to the layer of safety
that we've added, while at the
same time all but eliminating
the worry of having
lost or stolen keys.
And it's really
easy to get started.
You just upload your
key, create a new one,
and then you're done.
In fact, it's so easy,
I'm going to walk you
through the entire
process right now.
So log in to the new
look Play console.
You've seen the
material design, right?
Find the App Signing page.
It's under Release Management
in our new material design menu.
You need to read and
agree to the terms.
The change to go
into App Signing
is for the lifetime
of your app, so please
be sure that you want to
continue before you begin.
We don't intend to allow
withdrawal from the program.
If you wanted to change
the app signing key
or go back to
signing yourself, you
would need to create
a new package name
and release a new
app and migrate
all your users across similar
to losing your key today.
So please be sure that you want
to continue before you begin.
Next, you've got to find
your current key store file.
Here are some of
the common places
that developers have told us
that they keep their key--
your local development
machine, your CI server,
your code repository, or
maybe even a secure server.
Then you're going to download
our tool to encrypt your app
signing key.
This tool uses Google's
public key to encrypt your key
prior to network transfer.
If you want to inspect the
source code for this key,
this tool, you can.
Now select your
encrypted app signing key
and upload it to play
through the form.
Now you're going to
generate the new upload key.
This will be used to
authenticate your APK
uploads with Google.
We remove the signature and
re-sign with the original key
before distributing the app.
And you generate a new
key really simply using
the key tool.
Finally, you're ready
to register the upload
key with Google and
then enroll your app.
Once you click enroll, your
app has enrolled permanently,
and Play Console will
only accept uploads signed
with the upload
key, so please be
sure that you're ready
to transfer over.
And that's it.
You're done.
Hopefully the transition
is seamless and smooth,
just like it was for Roblox.
For new apps, it's even simpler.
We'll create and use a new app
signing key to sign your app
before it's deployed to users.
The key that you use to sign
your APK before uploading
to Play Console becomes
your upload key.
And that's it.
Now, Anthony is going to
talk about the security
aspects of this product.
ANTHONY MORRIS: Thanks, James.
So when we were
designing this product,
security was our
number one priority.
Google has a long history of
strong and ongoing investment
in security.
We have over 750
engineers at Google
working on our security systems.
And so we have built
upon that investment
in building this product.
So let me go into
some more detail
on some of the security features
of Google Play App Signing.
So I want to first
talk about the security
considerations involved with
importing your private keys.
In designing this
process, we wanted
to make sure it was
as secure as possible.
So James has explained
that in order
to encrypt your app signing
private key for transfer,
we provide you with
a simple command line
tool called the PEPK tool.
I like to call it Pepk.
It stands for Play
Encrypt Private Key.
So this tool exports your app
signing private key from a Java
key store, and then
encrypts it immediately,
ensuring that your private key
is never left in plain text
during this operation.
And if your keys are not
stored in a Java key store,
then we also provide the
source code of the tool
so you can write your own code
to export and encrypt your keys
from wherever they are stored.
The encryption we use is
public key hybrid encryption
based on Shoup's ISO standard.
Specifically, we use P256
elliptic curve asymmetric
encryption with AES
symmetric encryption.
And because we use asymmetric
encryption, once encrypted,
your App Signing
private key can only
be accessed by our internal
secure a key management system.
So intermediate servers along
the way can't access the key.
Now let's talk about our
secure a key management system,
a specific, dedicated service
for managing private keys.
And in managing these keys, we
follow industry best practices.
So in more detail,
the keys are never
exposed outside of the
system, and these keys
can only be used to sign the
APKs that you have uploaded.
And in particular, when
we go to sign an APK,
the signing operation is
performed within this system,
so the keys don't
leave the system
in order to sign your APK.
Furthermore, all
signing operations
performed are logged and
internally auditable,
and access to this system
is tightly restricted.
Now to protect the case
within this system,
we store the keys such that they
are strongly encrypted at rest.
The keys are never
stored in plain text.
And to prevent key loss, we
make very frequent backups
of our primary storage.
These backups are themselves
strongly encrypted,
and we regularly test
restoring from those backups.
You can find out
more information
about Google's security
practices in our public Google
security white papers
published online.
Finally, I want to talk
to you about this new key
we have introduced into the
process called the upload key.
As James has explained,
the upload key
is used by Google Play to verify
that the uploaded APK comes
from the correct developer.
We verify the validity of
the upload key signature
prior to signing with
the App Signing key.
Now unlike the App
Signing key, the upload
is only verified by Google Play
and not the Android framework,
and that means it's
possible to reset it in case
the developer loses
it or is compromised.
So if, in the
unfortunate situation
the upload key does become
lost or compromised,
you can contact Google
Play developer operations
and request that your upload
key be reset to a new upload
key that you generate.
This process will
take a couple of days,
as we will need to securely
verify your identity,
and then you can resume
uploading APKs by signing them
with your new upload key.
Now over to James to talk about
what enrolling in Google Play
App Signing enables
us to do for your app.
JAMES SMITH: Thanks, Anthony.
So, once Google
Play signs your app,
you can probably
guess what's coming.
We can also start to provide
optimization services
at your request.
So how is this possible?
You provide us an APK
signed with the upload key.
We verify your identity and
then remove that signature.
There is now a
window of opportunity
before that APK is signed
with your app signing key
where we can apply
optimizations to your app.
We want to use this
opportunity to provide services
to developers.
Think about it as applying the
power of Google and tech's best
practices to your app.
So the first optimization
we decided to focus on
is making apps smaller.
We think we can have
a great impact here.
We know that developers
care about APK size
because users do.
Download cancellations are
correlated with app size.
If a user attempts to download
an app and it takes too long
or it looks like it's
going to be too big,
it's more susceptible
to getting canceled.
And we know that
larger apps are more
likely to be uninstalled by
a user looking to free up
space on that device.
If you're interested
in what you can
do to make your
apps smaller, make
sure you check out the
video from the slimming
down your APK talk which
happened this morning.
ANTHONY MORRIS: So in looking
at how we could reduce app size,
we started by looking
at what takes up
the most space inside an APK.
So we analyzed all the
apps in the Play Store
and looked at the proportion
of space taken up by each file
type inside the average APK.
And the chart on
this slide shows you
the results of this analysis.
What you can say is that the
top contributors to APK size are
.so files, or native libraries,
and PNG files, images.
And together these take up
roughly 40% of an APK's size
on average.
Now if we look
inside some APKs, we
can see why these file
types take up so much space.
Here we have an
example APK where
we visualized the
contents of the APK
by size, the size of the boxes
indicating the relative size
of each component.
I'm sure many of your apps
would look similar to this.
What we see is that because
of the diversity of devices
in the Android ecosystem,
developers include native
libraries for different
architectures, so ARM, x86,
MIPS, sometimes the
64-bit variants as well,
and durables for different
screen densities--
Low density, medium
density, high density,
extra-high extra-extra high,
extra-extra-extra high.
We got really creative
at the end there.
And this is a good
thing, because it
means that apps run at
their best on each device.
They have images at the right
density and native libraries
compiled for the correct
architecture for that device.
But the consequence of this
is that for a specific device,
a lot of the content of
an APK is unnecessary.
So if I have a phone with
a 32-bit ARM architecture
and an HDPI screen,
then I only need
the contents of the boxes in
blue, and the boxes in green
are completely unnecessary and
unused for that specific phone.
But if I had a tablet with an
x86 architecture and an XXHDPI
screen, then I would need a
completely different subset
of the boxes.
Now you could in
the past manually
create device-specific APKs
by generating multiple APKs,
each with only one density
and one native architecture.
But it's a lot of
effort, and in fact we
recommended you didn't do this
because it's so complicated.
And so we found that less than
1% of apps on the Play Store
actually do this.
But now, as James explained,
with Google Play App Signing,
we can automatically
generate these APKs for you
and deliver to each device
only what that device needs.
So how does this
work in more detail?
So you, a developer,
uploads a universal APK
that contains drawables
for multiple densities
and native libraries for
multiple architectures.
Then from that universal APK,
we generate multiple APKs
that are optimized
for specific devices.
So for native
libraries, what we'll do
is we'll remove all the libs
directories except for the one
corresponding to the device's
preferred architecture.
So if you have an
x86 device, we will
remove the ARM and the MIPS
directories from the APK
that we will deliver
to that device.
For drawables we will remove
all the drawable resources
that would not be loaded for
that device's screen density.
So if you have
included an MDPI, HDPI,
and XHDPI version of
an image in your APK,
then for an MDPI
device, we will only
keep the MDPI
resource in the APK
that we deliver to that device.
And then after removing
these drawables,
we modify the resource
table accordingly
to no longer reference
these removed files.
Now because we only removed
native libraries and resources
that would not have been
loaded on that device
in the first place,
and keep the ones that
would have been
loaded by that device,
you should see no difference
in the behavior of your app,
except, of course, that
it would be smaller.
Now we call these APKs that
we generate derived APKs,
because as they are derived
from your uploaded APK.
Each of these derived APKs
will have the same version code
as the version code
in the uploaded APK,
and we add an extra
field in the manifest
that we call the derived APK ID
in order to distinguish them.
So then what does
this mean for you
if you are enrolled in
Google Play App Signing
and have enabled
these optimizations?
So it firstly and
most importantly means
that the APKs we
deliver to your users
are smaller, saving users'
bandwidth and space on disk.
It also means that if you were
previously reluctant to add
support for new architectures
or screen densities
because you worried about
bloating you APK, then now
you don't need to worry.
We've had developers
in the past tell us
they don't want to add support
for 64-bit architectures
because it will result in a
significant increase in the APK
size, but now since
we will only include
the necessary architectures
for each device in the APK
we send down, you can add
support for new architectures
without affecting
APK size for users.
Finally, if you were previously
building multiple APKs
for different densities or
different native architectures,
you won't need to anymore.
So instead of uploading
four different APKs
for different native
architectures or six
different APKs for different
screen densities, or maybe
you were really diligent
and had 24 different APKs,
each for a specific native
architecture and screen
density, now you
don't need to do that.
Now you can just upload
a single universal APK,
and Google Play will
do the work for you.
I'll hand back to James now to
talk about some of the results
we've seen with some
of our early partners.
JAMES SMITH: So hopefully
this is pretty cool, right?
Hopefully for you if
you are using multi APK,
this is going to change how
you build, how you do things,
hopefully make
things a lot better.
So we're just getting
started exploring this area,
and it's really
early, but we tried it
out with some apps that are
in our Early Access program,
and we expect the average
savings to be about 15%.
However, some apps see
even better results.
Deliveroo was 33% smaller
after optimizations,
and the 7 Minute Workout app was
nearly a half smaller at 48%.
When we talked to developers
about these changes,
they got really excited.
One developer said, "We just
put things in the right place
and Google does
the heavy lifting,"
and that's exactly
what we're going for.
You can do this yourself,
but it's complicated,
and we want to
offer services that
apply best practices
automatically for developers.
So how do you try this out?
Now to get started testing,
the first thing you should know
is that you can enable app
optimizations for specific APKs
when you upload them to Play.
That means that,
for example, you
could enable optimizations
for a specific app--
APK, excuse me,
and then try it out
in your Alpha or Beta channel.
You are using Alpha and
Beta channels, right?
We have over 250,000
developers using Alpha Beta,
and if you aren't already using
it then you probably should be.
They're a great way to
test out new features
on a subset of your users before
releasing the APK to everyone.
Once you're satisfied the
optimizations make sense
for your app, you can enable
APK optimizations for all APKs
that you upload.
If you want to
download and inspect
an APK that is signed by Play,
you can do this at any time
once they're generated, before
or after they're released.
After you upload an APK
to the Play console,
it generally takes
less than five minutes
to generate all of
the derived APKs,
and then you can go
into the new artifact
library in the Play console.
You're going to select
the APK that you uploaded
and click on the Download
button to get this pop up.
Now you can download
the original APK,
you can download a derived APK
by entering in the derived ID,
or you can type in
a specific device
to get the APK that Play
would send to that device.
ANTHONY MORRIS: You might also
want to try things out locally
during development without
uploading to the Play console
to see how your app will
perform when optimized.
So there are two ways
you can go about this
and simulate the
optimizations that we'll
do on the server side while you
are doing local development.
One way is you can temporarily
modify your Gradle config
to output the density and native
architecture optimized APKs,
just by adding the
line shown here.
What this will do is it
will cause your Gradle
build to output multiple
APKs, each targeted
to a single screen density
and native architecture.
Or you can build
your universal APK
that you would upload
to Play, and then
run a new command
that we've added
in aapt2 that would
generate the optimized APKs
from the universal APK.
This command is actually
what we run on the server
to generate the optimized APKs
from the APK that you upload.
One other important thing
to note for local testing
is that many APIs
and services require
that you register your signing
certificate of your app
in order for them to work.
For example, the Firebase
SDK, the Google Maps API,
and the Facebook SDK
all require this.
Now if you're testing
locally and you've
enrolled in Google Apps signing,
you will likely no longer
have access to the
app signing key,
as it will be managed
by Google Play.
So you're going to be
signing your local builds
with the upload
key or another key.
Remember to register this
local key in addition
to your app signing key with all
the relevant APIs and services
that your app users
in order to ensure
that your app will continue
to function correctly
when testing locally.
Finally, one other thing is
that we've also updated how
our in-app purchases
check against--
checks-- sorry.
We've also updated our
in-app purchase checks
to skip the certificate
check for users
that are registered
as licensed testers
to make local testing of
in-app purchases easier.
So if you want to test in-app
purchases without uploading
an APK to the Play console
or without having it signed
with the app signing
key, all you need to do
is register your account as a
licensed tester in the Google
Play console.
So over to James now
to wrap things up.
JAMES SMITH: OK.
So when can you get
Google Play App Signing?
Well, it's available today.
App Optimizations,
we're trialing in beta
with a few partners
at the moment,
and we're hoping to widen
the beta in the near future.
So if you're interested
in Optimizations,
please go ahead and
sign up for App Signing
as soon as possible.
So thank you very
much for listening.
You can come and see us later
in the Sandbox C across the way,
but we'll also take questions
just now if you have any.
There's mics here and
here in the audience.
Thanks very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]